We recently purchased a Bieber PEMF device.
You've said the EMF devices are beneficial.
Would you please describe what the benefit is?
And in particular, if it is beneficial
in cancer prevention.
So I do have a number of web pages on the PEMF
that talk about the benefits of the PEMF
and research on PEMF,
you know, that means that there's really two different types
of PEMF devices.
So let's talk about that a little bit here.
So make that a little bit bigger.
So, and a PEMF device is really measured
on the Gauss output.
That's the four simple electrical pulse
that the machine has put it out.
There are two different types of PEMF device.
A low Gauss PEMF device and a high Gauss PEMF device.
So a low Gauss PEMF device is what the Bieber would fall under.
Also, there's other machines on the market.
So the Bieber would be a low pulse,
a low Gauss PEMF that IMRS is another brand on low Gauss PEMF.
There's a number of other ones on the market
that are professionally low Gauss output PEMF devices.
A low Gauss output is something you will hardly,
the impact of the pulse of electrical impulse
is going to be very low.
You're not going to like feel this giant jolted impulse
into your body.
That's what you get with a high Gauss output.
So these devices, there's a brand called Pulse.
There's a brand called key MF for life.
For life, there's lots of other professional brands
that are high Gauss output.
It is generally thought in the market
that the high Gauss output devices are more beneficial
for serious diseases or injuries.
The low Gauss output devices are more beneficial for...
If you don't really have anything serious going on
then you just want to try to stay healthy
and you're just trying to help grow yourself
and help just balance your energy.
So what's the benefit of PEMF?
Well, a couple of different benefits.
PEMF does stimulate the nerves
so it can help decrease inflammation at a site.
But that's really mainly only the high Gauss units.
We'll do that.
So the high Gauss units can be real beneficial for injuries.
So they would be good for like, you know, use sprain your knee.
They would be good for, you know, you hurt your ankle,
you pull the muscle.
So injuries is...
And this is the number one use of PEMF in our country
is high Gauss output PEMF units.
I'm talking about professional use like in a clinic.
It would be high Gauss outputs for musculoskeletal injuries.
Very good for injuries because it can help decrease inflammation.
So they're good for that.
That's the number one reason why PEMF is used
in a clinical setting is for decrease inflammation
to help improve the outcome of injuries,
damage joints, et cetera like that.
High Gauss output machines are also gonna add charge
to a cell much more rapidly.
So I'm talking the difference in numbers here.
A low Gauss output would be a machine
that I would define as maybe less than 2,000 Gauss.
That's what would be defined as a low Gauss output machine
in my book.
High Gauss output machine would be really 2,000 Gauss
to, you know, 40,000 Gauss.
So the machine that we used in our office
when we had patients come to our office
was the pulse brand.
That's probably the number one brand
that another one called Megatronic brand.
And it put out about 30 to 35,000 Gauss.
Like the beamer puts out 700 Gauss.
So that's the difference.
The IMRS is less than 1,000 Gauss.
The beamer is about 700 Gauss at its highest setting.
So it's a big difference.
What is the difference?
It's the amount of electricity that's going through there.
So the benefit of a pulse electromagnetic frequency
is the electrical impulse that can help recharge a cell.
So your cell membranes act as a cellular charge
electrical charge for your body.
That's part of what the cell membranes do.
And when we get sick, our cell membranes
could lose their charge.
That could actually be measured.
And that is not a good thing.
So using a PEMF can be helpful for that.
Is it specifically helpful for cancer?
No, it's specifically helpful just for overall health.
Is a PEMF machine gonna kill cancer cells?
No, not at all.
So it's not a cancer killing device at all.
But increasing your cell charge will that be better
for your immune system?
Will that be better for your detoxification pathways?
Will that be better for just cell health?
Well, sure.
So indirectly, they're good for anybody regardless
whether you have cancer or not.
And if a person already has a beamer,
we'll go to say it's using it.
But if someone came to me and said,
what type of PEMF machine would be best to purchase?
I would not say a beamer.
I would not say an IMRS.
Now, it wasn't depends on your budget.
Because the higher ghosts out put machines cost more.
So the pulse machine that puts out 30 to 35,000 ghosts
cost me $38,000.
Well, that's very many people can fork out $38,000
for a pulse machine.
But our clinic bought that.
Now, the PEMF machines that we sell on our store
to patients are relatively would fall
into the high-gouls output.
But it puts out a maximum of about $6,000.
Well, those costs like $8,000.
They're expensive.
So I don't know how much you paid for your beamer.
But you can get an IMRS.
I think those are sold, you know,
knocks through multi-level marketing type things.
So I think you can get an IMRS for about $8,000.
IMRS for about $3,000 to $4,000.
But I think it's equivalent to the beamer.
So I don't know how much you paid for the beamer.
Maybe you got it used and you got a good deal
or some friend gave it to you.
I have no idea.
But those are low-gouls output machines.
And I don't think they're nearly as beneficial
for cancer patients or somebody with any serious disease
or somebody with peripheral neuropathy.
So that's another really great use of PEMF
is if I have peripheral neuropathy from chemotherapy.
Well, the PEMF helps stimulate the nerves
and can help heal the nerves so that it can help decrease
peripheral neuropathy symptoms.
But the low-gouls output machines,
they're not going to have nearly the same benefit.
So that's a little spiel on PEMF.
Unfortunately, a PEMF, whether it's low-gouls output
or high-gouls output, the salespeople
for these companies steal the research
that was done on PEMF.
All the research that's done with PEMF
is done with high-gouls output machines just so you know.
So all the research that you'll find in the literature
on PEMF and all the benefits are done
with high-gouls output machines.
And then the salespeople for the low-gouls output machines
steal that literature and see, see, this is what the PEMF does.
Look at all this research.
Well, yes, it does, but that's not what a low-gouls output machine does.
It's just, it's just the way it is so.